[Music]
hello my name is kuang Shu I'm a
professor of operation research at the
Stanford GSB I work on applying Ai and
data science to solving business
problems today I'm here to tell you
about a class I teach called data
science and AI strategy and here are
five key
takeaways data science and AI is not a
monolith and we learned this class that
there are at least two pillars to it the
one pillar being analytics and Reporting
and this is where a team would use data
science machine learning and statistics
to derive insight to drive strategic
decision- making they're typically
consumed by an internal audience on the
other hand we have ai driven decision-
making and these are automated tools
typically software used to generate
pricing recommendation often turned into
the form of a product in understanding
these two pillars there are pretty
significant implications for one we want
want to understand that when hiring a
team analytics reporting requires huge
amount of communication skills and the
ability to convince stakeholders while
on the other hand when you're building a
product using data science and AI you
really want to pay attention to
engineering and product
[Music]
design one often underestimates the
technical risks involved in developing
Ai and data science Solutions the reason
is as follows in traditional engineering
or product design such as as software
development it is it's often easier to
measure the incremental progress you're
making as you develop new features and
capability this is not true when it
comes to Ai and data science often times
you have to make a huge upfront
investment collecting data training
model and then there's the intrinsic
uncertainty of whether the model works
or not and how well it works therefore
you won't see the result until the very
end having spent a lot of time and
resources there are ways we can go into
to mitigate this risk but at the high
level what we want to think about is to
as much as possible Define incremental
Milestones to Der risk the process and
making sure that you are constantly
making progress as you go
along the third takeaway is that data by
itself is often times not emote it is
very compelling and intuitive sometimes
to try to build a large data set as your
compe advantage but here's a risk as you
collect more and more data initially the
data you get speaks to the most common
consumers they're cheap to get and yet
has huge business impact
but as you build into the niche area of
the corner cases the data becomes hard
to obtain while at the same time the
consumer base you're speaking to keeps
shrinking so initially you start with
low cost and high value and you venture
into the territory of high cost of
acquisition and low consumer value so if
you're building a company and thinking
about using data as your compe advantage
just be careful often times it is much
better to get enough data so your models
can be sufficiently trained while at the
same time time devoting the remaining
resources into designing better products
and better
Services think about what you truly need
before you look at what AI can offer
this is actually nothing new when a new
technology came onto the scene often
times Business Leaders and and decision
makers can get a little bit afraid
they're afraid to miss out on the
greatest opportunity therefore instead
of focusing on their business needs they
look at the capability of the technology
and the great showcases they have and
build that thing internally when they
don't truly truly need it so instead
here's a tip maybe you can put a
blindfold on your eyes pretend that Ai
and machine learning never existed ask
yourself what you truly need to build in
your company today and tomorrow to make
a grow then unfold yourself look at all
the technology that's available all the
advancements but now confining yourself
to only using them to building these
capabilities that you committed to and
that way you will use AI as a great tool
and not as some technology that might
lead you as TR into bad
[Music]
decisions unlike traditional engineering
and product design the output of AI data
science can often be an Insight that is
quite intangible and even looks a bit
obvious post the fact however these
insights often dictate the direction of
the product or even the direction of the
entire company so if you have a team
like that make sure you set up the
evaluation procedure correctly so that
your data scientists and AI researchers
have the incentive to explore and
hopefully discover these really really
important insights that will take your
business to the next
[Music]
stage AI is moving so fast but how do
you know it hasn't taken my job already
how do you know that it is me speaking
to you right
now